had y'all had any of y'all met before
this movie
yeah we did we knew each other we all
knew each other the three of us knew
each other but actually working as
intensely as we did on this film no we
didn't actually so i'm so honored to
have worked with the two of them
they're so talented uh deaf actors and
they
it was really more special to have
amelia on board with us as well this is
the perfect cast you'll never see a more
perfect cast
i could not agree more it was and i've
never seen it on film that's why i think
this is so important in film i've never
seen a full cast like this i never
really had to watch or pay attention in
a different way it was such a beautiful
and needed experience that i did not
know that i needed and i did not know
that american language it's
so passionate it's a passionate language
i mean it's just it's a full body it's
not you're not just using your voice
it's a full-body experience of how
deeply hurt you are or how deeply in
love you are or you know frustrated you
are it was just such an amazing thing to
watch exactly it's because
it's two things we are able to
[Music]
express ourselves our language
that's within deaf culture but we're
also damn good actors so that's all you
could say i mean when you're doing asl
yeah
but
but
this movie is one that most people the
majority of people probably aren't
accustomed to i mean they're all other
kinds of movies and those are all
wonderful films but this is unique and
it's special in itself and the fact that
there are so many different levels
operating at the same time in the film
people will connect to whatever level
that they're watching in the film
whether it's fishing or songs or music
or sign language or schools or teenage
life or family life it's all in one film
it's the entire package it's a beautiful
wonderful package for the audience
[Music]
you